once again protests against police
violence and systemic racism in the
United States filled towns and cities
across the country but Friday's
demonstrations had added poignancy it
was June 19th celebrated as Juneteenth a
day commemorating the end of slavery in
the u.s. I always fantasize on June TV
being looked at like July 4th
Independence Day for the people actually
it means Independence for and now it
seems like it has actually come to pass
this year since the protests began
following the police killing of George
Floyd in Minneapolis federal and local
politicians have pledged to reform the
police New York State for example has
criminalized chokeholds but activists
point out that New York City had already
outlawed the strangling of suspects by
police in 1993 yet according to filed
police complaints the practice is still
widespread that's why the call that
these demonstrations isn't for reform
but reimagining the entire system of law
and order
beginning with defunding the police
redirecting money from militarized force
to a system that prioritizes
de-escalation and healing social
problems that police in Atlanta where
there are also demonstrations have
reacted in fury to the arrest of a
police officer who shot a black man in
the back and then declared I got him as
another sign for some that the time for
mere reform has passed in Washington DC
protesters took a knee at the Martin
Luther King jr. memorial and then
marched to the Lincoln Memorial the
significance of this particular protest
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial on
June teens but at a time of
unprecedented nationwide protests about
systemic racism was so important to the
organizers this is where dr. King gave
his 1963 speech about his dream of
economic and racial justice and the
false promises of Lincoln's Emancipation
Proclamation this location was very
deliberate and it's very symbolic we
wanted this to be more than just another
protest
collective voices to be loud enough that
they hear us and that they understand
that we will not stop doing this until
you answer our calls for chains here a
man said I have a dream and this
generation will see that dream through
and 57 years after dr. King spoke here a
multiracial coalition for racial justice
appears to be holding she Abraham see
al-jazeera
Washington